les ébats de bosser vous revenez du
festival de cannes où le film la femme
de mon frère de monia chokri dans lequel
vous incarnez leurs principales aires a
remporté le prix coup de coeur du jury
un certain regard
donc c'est votre ami qui devrait
accompagner près intervention non oui
enfin je sais ma peine je sais ça toi
conte de fée pour vous tout seul de
dette à la cades de revenir mais c'est
sûr que je pouvais pas prévoir que tout
cela arrive et là je veux dire c'est le
plus beau scénario possible quand on
embarque dans un projet après ça j'ai
fait ça j'ai pas dit d'après moi le film
de monia chokri va se rendre à cannes
voilà qui est un move bien stratégique
de ma part ça s'est pas passé comme ça
mais c'est tôt encore pour en parler on
dirait que je réalise pas tout ce qui
s'est passé mais je sais quand que coup
de coeur c'est un vraiment un beau prix
cet accord parce que moi j'ai
l'impression qu'elle est très rigide
hollis jambes elle met potentiellement
mortes à l'intérieur à l'eau un peu du
tour à par l'acteur skylander c'est que
vous avez dit que vous avez pas de temps
carrière mais par contre depuis votre
sortie du conservatoire d'art dramatique
en 2007 vous avez vraiment pas chômé
vous avez tout le temps travaillé une
des comédiennes les plus occupés du show
business québécois
comment vous expliquez ça j'ai la
rechercher de l'émission qui est juste à
quelques mètres de moi je pense qu'il va
y intéressent montré discret parce que
je connais d'autres actrices qui ont été
stratégique qui sont 10 à des refus qui
sont stratégiques refuse un petit rôle
ça me donne envoyer le message que tu es
un grand rôle nous achevons plus que ça
je pense j'ai plus à vraiment moi j'ai
pas mal j'ai pas dit oui à tout mais
j'ai dit oui à beaucoup de choses et
j'ai davantage de faire de l'impro ça
m'a sorti de sa me sentir de l'eau
chaude très souvent dans ma vie après ce
bain
moi j'aime jouer donc j'aime jouer du
web j'aime le cinéma j'aime jouer du
théâtre jeux pour sap tels que je me
suis beaucoup diversifiés puis le meur
au québec très grande force c'est un
atout qui nous sert parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de comédies les gens aiment
rire
donc ça c'est les comédiens qui ont
l'âme la carte comique les sont choyés
parce que ça peut être long gain de
motocross sertis de pierres précieuses
c'est pour façon possible succès ça va
être les spaghettis où ils sont l'humour
ans n'est pas une improvisation les
appendices aussi où vous êtes fait
connaître beaucoup savaient jouer un
carnet des centaines de personnages avec
ce lien d'où ce petit côté drôle chez
hexadome beauce m il vient de d'aussi
loin que je me souvienne moi et mon
frère on a consommé énormément d'humour
quand on était jeunes - des premiers
cadeaux que j'ai voulu aller voir un
hymne au récent spectacle spécu steve
martin dans le film la femme de mon
frère vous incarnez une femme qui est à
la croisée des chemins dans la mi
trentaine personnage qui ressemble
beaucoup à maxim lapierre dans les
semaines d'ailleurs louis est ce que ce
genre de crise existentielle
je la femme dans la mi trentaine c'est
quelque chose qui vous interpelle comme
thème comme personnage oui bah oui tout
à fait parce que c'est facile de
s'identifier à ces périodes de la vie on
en a toutes les périodes de crise
quelque chose avec la trentaine qui les
choix en plus de conséquences
je pense que c'est moi je fais face à
ces au site et qu'on pense à la
maternité ou compenser mon choix de
carrière que je peux faire on a
l'impression qu'il ya des partis sonic
et aussi des portes qui se ferment ce
qu'on sent pas l'âme interne donc ces
riches comme terreau autant mousson si
on peut se servir de nos propres
expériences pour pour jouer sur six
communication création de consultation
bourg d'événementiel que remplir
québécois qui pense qu'il ya quelque
chose avec notre génération qui cherche
à venir maintenant on cherche des
émotions extrêmes en charge du bonheur
totaux on a des difficultés avec les
situations hybride on a discuté qui
sacrifie son oeuvre
on veut un retour instantané des choses
moi j'ai fait de la projection d'une
réaction immédiate public quand les
questions de long processus où il ya pas
de gratification à court terme
on a beaucoup de difficulté avec ça
c'est vrai que je le vois hélas il
talons dont elle pas ta lancée par
l'espagne et si vous êtes une grecque
il ya un thème ou si récurrent qui
revient dans vos films dans vos séries
c'est ce qu'on mange ce qu'on ne mange
pas ça remet toujours le soir oui c'est
vrai le poil image au sens harper encore
aujourd'hui mais bien sûr donc je
comprends qu'il ya une grosse campagne
du body partez pas été visible je
comprends on a vraiment besoin de se le
rappeler mais on dirait que je trouve
pourrait tout à fait renaître en
contrant chez les autres tu es belle
reste de même et pour soi se dire ça
tout le monde et tout le monde est à 5
livres du bonheur 10 15 20 exactement
c'est comment se sortir de ce cours là
dans le monde dans lequel on vit ce pont
pour moi c'est pas vrai que ça a changé
on est entouré de recettes des régimes
de cosmétiques de botox de jeunesse
éternelle
encore plus dans mon métier je voudrais
c'est un travail constant de se
connecter sur l'intérieur sur les les
vraies valeurs parce que honnêtement je
pense pas que c'est derrière nous pas du
tout analysé pas de bosser merci
beaucoup merci parce que tu penses que
en étant riche je serai plus
heureusement mais je serais malheureux
au soleil se réunit le privé mais je me
ferai des traitements au laser quentin
cellulite